.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: HERE TO REACT TO THE
BREAKING NEWS AUTHOR OF THE TEN
WEEK IN A NUMBER 1 "NEW YORK
TIMES" BEST SELLER AMERICA
MARXISM, I CALL HIM THE GREAT
ONE.
A QUICK REACTION TO THAT.
YOU KNOW THE PEOPLE THAT GO TO
THE MILITARY ACADEMIES.
WE MET THEM.
THE MOST AMAZING PEOPLE ON
EARTH.
WILLING TO RISK THEIR LIVES AND
SACRIFICE FOR THEIR COUNTRY.
YOU WOULD THINK THERE WOULD BE
A TYPE OF CREATIVE WAY TO SOLVE
A PROBLEM SHORT OF OUR WAY OR
THE HIGHWAY.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY LISTENING TO THOSE
WONDERFUL PATRIOTS THERE IS THAT
THE GOVERNMENT IS WEEDING OUT
PEOPLE WHO JUST DON'T GO WITH
AUTHORIT
AUTHORITARIANISM.
MANY PEOPLE 2 HAVE NATURAL
IMMUNITY WILL BE FIRED WITH AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ILLEGAL MANDATE
WITH JOE BIDEN.
OSHA HAS NO AUTHORITY OVER
VACCINES.
IF ANY DEPARTMENT AND THEY DON'T
IT WOULD BE HHS.
THIS WILL BE DEFEATED.
IT'S THE MENTALITY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO WEED OUT
FORCES THAT SUPPORT FREEDOM AND
REJECT AUTHORITY.
THE WAR ON THE COPS IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE AND THE WAR ON THE
MILITARY IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
IT'S GOING ON THROUGHOUT THE
AMERICAN MARXISM MOVEMENT.
THIS BOOK IS NOT IN OUR SCHOOLS?
WHY NOT?
THIS IS THE ANTIDOTE TO WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE PARENTS IN VIRGINIA AND
ELSEWHERE WHO ROSE UP.
THE PARENTS IN VIRGINIA, BEING
A PARENT MYSELF AS ARE YOU,
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS POISON.
IT'S MORE THAN CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO YOUR
CHILDREN IS OUTRAGEOUS.
WHAT KIND OF A COUNTRY ARE WE
GOING TO LEAVE TO OUR CHILDREN
AND GRANDCHILDREN AND
GENERATIONS YET BORN?
THIS MOVEMENT IS ACROSS THE
BOARD.
THIS RADICAL MOVEMENT.
WHO WILL PAY THIS DEBT?
WE HAVE MORONIC STATEMENTS FROM
THE PRESIDENT AND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THAT THEY WILL SPEND
TRILLION DOLLARS IN DEBT BUT IT
DOESN'T CREATE DEBT, IN FACT IT
WILL ELIMINATE THE DEBT.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THEY WILL EXPAND MEDICARE WHICH
WILL DESTROY MEDICARE.
WHO WILL PAY FOR THAT?
IT'S A RACISM AND A RADICAL LEFT
AGENDA.
TEST SCORES ARE GOING DOWN IN
EVERY PART OF THIS COUNTRY.
WHAT ABOUT IMMIGRATION?
A LACK OF ASSIMILATION.
THE BORDER IS WIDE OPEN.
YOU WILL HAVE TRIBUNALIZATION IN
THE YEARS AHEAD.
WHAT KIND OF COUNTRY ARE WE
LEAVING OUR CHILDREN.
-- WE HAVE THIS MOVEMENT THAT IS
A WAR ON CAPITALISM AND PRIVATE
PROPERTY RIGHTS.
THIS IS THE CORE OF AMERICANISM.
THEY CREATE LAWLESS INNOCENCE
WITH THEIR AGENDA.
WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY?
-- CHINA IS BUILDING A MILITARY
PREPARED FOR WAR.
OUR MILITARY IS BEING GUTTED AND
UNDERMINED WITH THIS SOCIAL
AGENDA.
THIS CRITICAL RACE THEORY AND
A THOUSAND OTHER WAYS.
IT'S NOT PROPERLY FUNDED.
WE ARE NOT BUILDING UP OUR
MILITARY.
ONE DAY OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN BECAUSE OF THE
PROVOCATIVE NATURE OF THE
MARXISTS IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WILL HAVE TO GO TO WAR FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
LOOK AT THE CONSTITUTION.
WE INHERITED THE GREATEST
DOCUMENT ON THE FACE OF THE
EARTH IT'S UNDER CONTACT ATTACK.
A WAR ON THE BILL OF RIGHTS.
WHAT KIND OF A COUNTRY ARE WE
CREATING AND LEAVEING TO OUR
CHILDREN.
THE SAME PARENTS THAT ROSE UP AT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS -- THE
SAME PARENTS CONCERNED ABOUT
CRITICAL RACE THEORY AND
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS TRANSGENDER
MOVEMENT AND THE SAME PARENTS
WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WHO
SHOULD CONTROL WHAT IN THEIR
CHILDREN'S LIVES.
YOUR CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN
AND GENERATIONS YET BORN ARE
PLUNDERED BY JOE BIDEN AND CHUCK
SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI AND BY
AOC AND TALIB.
BY THIS RADICALISM.
TALIB.
WE NEED TO BE RESOLUTE.
A VICTORY IS A BEAUTIFUL THING.
THIS IS ONE BATTLE AFTER ANOTHER
AND AFTER ANOTHER -- A BATTLE
OVER THE CULTURE AND THE ECONOMY
AND A BATTLE OVER CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLICANISM.
EVERY ONE OF THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLES THAT GAVE US LIFE,
LIBERTY AND PROSPERITY IS UNDER
ATTACK BY THE DEMOCRAT PARTY.
BY THE SURROGATES IN THE MEDIA
AND ENTERTAINMENT.
THE VICTORIES THE OTHER NIGHT IS
ONE SMALL STEP TO PROTECT THE
FUTURE OF OUR CHINA.
-- CHILDREN.
STEP UP AND FIGHT THE SCHOOL
BOARDS AND FIGHT THIS AGENDA
COMING OUT OF WASHINGTON THAT
WILL DESTROY THE FUTURE OF YOUR
CHILDREN AND DEVOUR THEIR
OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT'S IT.
>> Sean: THAT'S WHY WE CALL HIM
THE GREAT ONE M